en el campo peruano alejado de las
grandes ciudades costeras la
conectividad a internet no está
totalmente garantizada y en esta aldea
de la Sierra peruana la llegada del 4G
comienza a cambiar vidas y hasta
ilusionar con nuevos proyectos
Gladys quiere comercializar por internet
los productos de su finca hacer una
empresa de que esos yogures manjar todo
pero ya con una asociación que tenemos
ya todas trabajamos internet llega a la
aldea y con ella también las clases que
es de la pandemia dependían de la
tecnología Cuando recién inició la
pandemia disculpe que por el internet el
celular no podíamos conectar con los
profesores teníamos que ir a un cerro al
Cerrito para Buscar señal la brecha
digital entre las zonas Rurales y
urbanas es una de las razones que
convierte a Perú en el cuarto país más
desigual en el mundo según el centro de
investigación working y Quality lab
laboratorio desigualdad mundial en
español
internet para todos proyecto de la
empresa meta el banco interamericano de
desarrollo y el banco de desarrollo de
América Latina Busca combatir esta
tendencia en Perú con internet para
todos en estos casi cuatro años hemos
cubierto casi 16.000 centros poblados en
todo el país zonas Rurales centros
poblados en zonas Rurales a pesar de los
avances en la región la libertad donde
se ubica la aldea aún quedan
aproximadamente
140.000 personas que no tienen cobertura
a internet